[Music]
have you guys seen this one photo of a
Russian nurse that went viral when she
decided to take her scrubs off yeah and
then instead had that transparent PPE
covering yes I think I have photo we did
it Jackie news about it here you go you
perv what do you call those kind of bras
that style it's pretty nice last time we
didn't see your faces I damnit I did
further research yeah yeah a little your
face does goggle picture looks me scary
yeah which one no doctor would yeah oh
it's the goggles and like the killer you
know what's funny about that though in
the back in the back there's a guy just
staring at her and it's a old man
there's two guys yeah yeah they're all
just staring at us well the context of
this photo here is that she is a Russian
nurse and she says that it just got way
too hot to have her scrubs under cuz she
took like yeah so she ended up taking
over scrubs she's there she says that
she didn't realize how transparent this
thing was and I get it cuz I've worn
these before and they don't look that
transparent like people put them from
far away you're like oh shoot you can
see through those things well I guess
that's not very far away but didn't she
put it on and go yeah this is
transparent after this went viral now
she's in the news again because she has
gotten a modeling contract with a sports
sportswear brand Wow oh here she is
don't you think that she's actually
curing Co vid with that outfit on people
need some hope yeah this brand Russian
brand that's her probably she doesn't
even look the same well she had makeup
in the other photo no one this is a more
natural style makeup she's kind of cute
though still you are extreme today no no
I'm not saying she ugly I'm just saying
it's just like a different person did
she get in trouble for like the other
thing how come she keeps taking pictures
in the bathroom bathroom yeah there's
nothing
and pictures cuz of the tile like did
she get in trouble for like being
scandalous uh I think I think she did
yeah she got in trouble with their
higher-ups
she got a modeling contract there's you
got a Marlin card yeah exactly that's
pretty tight so she got a better career
she came no well not a better career
it's more like oh she still plans on
being in health care because that's what
she loves but it's just kind of like I
don't miss it this is a bonus it's like
you win some you lose some hot people
are lucky oh just throwing it out there
Wow hot privileged hot privileged hot
privileged I just think how people got
it better they got it easier
of course there's of course there's
deviants in gray area you know they're
less likely to be like charged with
heavier crimes yeah they're likely to
just have more people gravitate toward
that you're able to trust it more for
some reason like Ted Bundy right
good-looking people yeah you can trust
that's true because I don't trust ugly
people straight-up look at I'm like well
you look at the mirror they also get
tipped higher like in the drawers in
this hell yeah you got mad tips then I
did well not my way we never got more
tips can be a social experiment cuz I
cuz I had heard about this but I wasn't
sure if those two and when a week of
serving without makeup and then I
compared that to the next week like
doing my makeup to the nines I made more
than double the makeup on for sure all
the girls theme shifts gotten way more
money than the guy waiters well we know
what that makes me think of it kind of
it kind of makes me sad a little bit cuz
it makes me think of those like
significantly older women who are still
like waitressing in the casinos in Vegas
and they feel like really like it's not
fair it's like as yeah cuz they're
pretty ugly no it's not fair
just kidding just kidding me you know
what it is though you're looking at it
at your beauty standards right there's a
[ __ ] guy out there with the oxygen
tank playing on the [ __ ] they're
playing on a [ __ ] machine and
here comes he's gonna show your audience
if you're that
big boob girl and he's like oh dear you
are so hot because girls are hella
judgmental man there's like stripper
posters over there and I remember don't
be like that goes about that huh I'm
like what you mean it's a subconscious
bias for sure because like you're it's
from a very young age you're shown like
who is yeah who's hot ones and even now
like in feature films if you look like
lead guys can get schlubby ur like how's
the lead but the girls cannot can what
slugger me like that buggin yeah like
dad bod like oh unkept yeah like nerdy
do it them actresses need to be like
Margot Robbie yeah why is it hot hot I
think because girls don't value physical
as much as guys do yeah so they did a
study of like 10 high traits that you
want in a mate for guys like physical
attraction is always like 1 or 2 it's
it's really high and then for women it's
not even in the top five sometimes e6
like in Nikki's case like she says that
funny guys she just not even sexually
attracted until someone is a funny
person whereas for most majority of men
it's like maybe it'll differ depending
on culture but they want physical looks
first I will say like even in my girl
groups like a lot of the girls really
like attractive guys still like
physically attractive guys so I feel
like almost an oddball sometimes cuz
humour is important but maybe they put
it lower than yes whereas I feel like I
put it number one I think that looks are
important to both genders yeah and where
women value I think yeah they have way
more other factors that's combined with
physical and it could be biological too
yeah I think it is for sure point is hot
people are luckier how lucky though was
because for example like Bernie to be so
beautiful I ever heard of that like it's
a person I'm so beautiful it's a curse
that's why cosmetic surgery's thriving
because like anybody can if you weren't
born hot you can make yourself hot look
at and it becomes an addiction for [ __ ]
hotter than you were before
yeah and
sometimes those people like they do one
thing let's say and they get treated
better or they feel like they're being
treated better after they got that one
procedure done so then they're like well
[ __ ] that much from this one then what
happens if I also get a boob job what
happens if I also get a Butt Lift what
happens if I also get you know and then
just they start becoming like it's
becoming an addiction what do you think
happen with Michael Jackson then he got
better like oh no I like the nose do you
want to be Peter Pan he literally wanted
to be Peter Pan but like he has like a
triangle like no nose his thing was that
vitiligo and like these things were
[ __ ] up his outer limbs like fingers
and nose and ears that's why you'll see
a lot of tape on his outer fin how do
you explain his sister she has the same
nose nobody Oh Janet no no Janet look
Tanya Latoya I don't know but this is
dare what he his statement was or like
why he'd caught that nose or whatever
but and I personally think he wanted to
look like Peter Pan oh so you don't know
that for a fact
that's a fan theory my bad theory but
but he but but the statement about the
whole vitiligo and the day and the
medical thing that was that yeah slash
slash I also didn't he also get a lot of
trauma from like his dad or getting made
fun of his like big nose and stuff like
that yeah oh yeah that's a big part too
yeah so like just like the opposite of
what Nicky was saying right sometimes
people will feel validated after they do
something and they treated better or
whatnot you know there's also probably
people that are like treated poorly for
something that they may have about
themselves oh and he hated seeing his
dad in his face so that's why he got
cosmetic surgery to look oh yeah and I
think that's why all of it is because he
wanted to look like Peter Pan I think
you legitly wanted to fight the cartoon
version but is it or the live-action nah
hook not live-action with the female
lead oh oh the old live-action yeah yeah
I don't know that was before there was
CGI name like gee I forget heard me I
forget - I just remember how I remember
it and I remember being like oh my Peter
Pan and my babysitter put on that when I
was like this is not the one
there is a difference between what guys
find hot as a woman standard of beauty
and in what women find hot as a woman
standard of beauty I think even guys and
guys can't even agree
yeah there's different it's something
some people want curvier women some guys
like the skinny ones you know I guess
and then demographically like
state-to-state like cuz a lot of the
truth
la girls start looking the same yeah
actually like the makeup styles yeah and
like everyone kind of wants to look like
one person that like the trend goes for
a few years we're like right now I feel
like everyone's trying look like
Kardashians that's true and then like
who knows who it will be next who is
before like Pam Anderson was like the
90s like everyone was trying to be
blonde big boobs
JLo JLo came in and changed the games of
the butt true she looks good for like a
fifty year old man she looks good she
looks good period ham this is one photo
she's at the beach and I'm like why me
why she does so much to earn it though
like she works hard for that beauty
really does she drink a lot of water a
lot and she never touches alcohol and
she eats like super clean
I've never even [ __ ] touch alcohol
what happened there
it was the men
[Music]
[Music]
you